foreign
Jamie is with us Jamie is in Springfield
Illinois hi Jamie how are you
hi Dave thanks for having me
um I wanted to ask you and Rachel today
I've been following the Ramsay way for
several years now and I am on baby step
seven I'm 100 debt free as far as
student loans credit cards I even paid
off my mortgage a couple years ago way
to go a couple months ago a couple
months ago sorry
um I have my emergency fund I'm saving
for retirement but where I'm just really
kind of struggling and I'm afraid I
guess a little bit because I'm not
budgeting well and so I'm afraid to like
just spend freely and not I'm just not
doing budgeting very well and I guess
that's what I want your information or
you know your knowledge or advice on
Jamie what what's causing you not to do
you think what's the what's what's the
reason behind not budgeting well would
you say
I don't know I'm just I honestly haven't
I've never done it well
um I think the
um gazelle intends to pay off all the
things helped me to get there and now
here I am I'm like okay I'm making more
I have a side Hustle but I don't have
anything that I have to pay so I think
there was always that like you know yeah
the urgency is gone basically yeah and
now I'm like okay now what yeah totally
well I think one thing that you said
that for me because I'm more of a
natural spender and all of it so my
natural bent is not towards budgeting
and everything is what you're saying I'm
like I totally get it uh but what I have
found is that and you you touched on
earlier so I want to just say your words
back to you that you don't feel the
freedom to spend and so for me that is
what I have found so great about
budgeting is it it allows me to be able
to spend and not second guess myself or
not think about it so I mean I can tell
you Jamie my husband I were in baby step
seven I mean we've been doing this for
12 years and I our budget I mean we just
did April and I'm like it's it's so
consistent there may be like four or
five categories that we change month to
month but for the most part we know what
we spend and for us it's it it has
become so simple because it's been so
consistent we're not in this
um flux of stuff right like especially
if you're on baby steps one through
three there's so much of like oh my gosh
where can we squeeze out where can we
look but maybe step seven you can kind
of relax in that and I think that makes
almost budgeting can be a little bit
easier because uh again those budgets
are are so much more consistent month to
month so I would be curious if you
really did buckle down and do every
dollar Plus for just three months I bet
by the end of the summer you're like
okay this isn't as strenuous or as hard
as I was thinking uh and we talk about
two in baby step seven that you know you
you can up your lifestyle a certain
percentage you have your giving a
certain percentage and all of that again
it's a little bit more relaxed because
like you said you're not having to be as
focused and as a as intense with every
single penny so when you say you're are
not budgeting well do you mean you're
not pinching pennies or do you mean
you're not functionally tactically doing
the budget well
pennies and I am not physically doing a
budget you know
because at your stage we're not we don't
tell you to pinch pennies at your stage
all I want you just to do is to do it on
purpose
and the writing it down makes you do it
on purpose and to that end
um like what is something that a
category give me a category you enjoy
spending on enjoy freedom in
sure I mean clothes travel what
vacations vacations okay all right see I
to me if you say this is what we're
going to spend on a vacation this is
what we're going to put aside for a
vacation and then when I get ready to do
the vacation the money is laying there
because I put it in there
um that's easier and and the vacation is
more relaxing and more fun than not
knowing if I screwed something else up
by going on vacation
yeah yeah that makes sense that's what
Rachel's saying there's freedom in the
plan because it you know like if for
instance if it was clothing and you went
and bought something in clothing and
there was Zero guilt because it was in
the clothing budget you know I mean
that's what it's supposed to be used for
for God's sakes and so you can relax and
enjoy the clothing purchase that way
um
and uh you know then you're not outside
you're not out of bounds and you just
the the feeling of knowing you're you're
not messing up things when you buy
something because there's a a latent
guilt with buying the wrong thing in the
wrong time that puts you into a mess and
you want to that's a good guilt because
it keeps you from doing stupid butt
stuff right but you're it takes away the
fear that you're doing something stupid
but if you've got a written game plan
where everything's assigned and so I
think the freedom is what I would reach
for that Rachel's talking about
okay just a mindset change yeah it's
going to give me by doing the my my
payoff for sitting down and spending
that one hour and later spending 30
minutes because it doesn't take 30
minutes to do it once you kind of got a
rhythm going but you know and really
getting good at it the freedom the
payoff for that one hour is freedom I
can without guilt without hesitation
go out to eat because I got that go out
to eat budget right right and I don't
have to go well we kind of blew it we
went out to eat again you don't have to
have that latent thing hanging over your
head and I I just think that's a that
you know uh we used to call it uh before
Rachel kind of took it and said you know
this this is It's freedom to spend it's
but we just used to call we said Okay
We're not gonna call it a budget anymore
we'll call it a spending plan yeah yeah
because that's what it is I don't care
what you do with your money as long as
you do it on purpose because people
seldom do stupid butt stuff on purpose
let's sit down let's see if we can do a
stupid butt thing right now nobody does
that
but it's like we just keep driving
driving oh the car's out of gas who knew
yeah you know and I think Jamie the
encouragement thing where you are
because you have been so diligent with
your money you have worked hard a lot of
room and paid off debt and I mean yeah
you you have the margin or you should I
mean to have have the margin to be able
to say hey we're going to just do big
categories within the budget and not
every single one I think the further
back you are on the baby steps the even
more detailed you know in meticulous you
need to be and then as you start moving
it's like oh you can kind of make these
bigger wider categories and live within
those and it's still okay but you're
still doing it on purpose yeah let me
give you an example of that for the rest
of you out there not for her
when you first start doing your budget
you should have a separate restaurants
envelope from your grocery store
envelope
you should have a separate category
restaurant should be a separate category
you shouldn't just say food
because if you just say food when you're
first starting you'll eat out and you
won't have any money to go to the
grocery store yeah you know but when you
separate those two but then later on
when you you know you've gotten under
control you've gotten rid of the debt
you've got the margin then you could
just have food you know what's funny
though about me I'm like I should like
retake my know yourself know your money
assessment because I even might be more
of a nerd than I realize because even
though we're on baby step seven and
we've been again doing this we're not
perfect at it but it's been over a
decade I still like more individual
categories because I just want I just
want to like you like the clarity I like
the clarity of just the complete like I
have a date that's not motivated by
nerdism though that's motivated by the
free spending I know like we have a
freedom date date nights in our food
category so it's like it's a separate
yeah because I'm like I want to enjoy
you want to go out to eat on date night
okay I got you all of it I don't know
we're so specific on ours but that's
then you can do it without guilt that's
what you like what I like about it yeah
I like it it's a freedom there's a
freedom to it and that that's where
budgeting is not a punishing process
it's a spending plan this is the Ramsey
Show